I have two questions the first is do you
believe national sovereignty to believe
to be the most important value and the
second one is what do you think about
about the Kantian idea of global
citizenship and do you believe yourself
to be a global citizen or other citizen
of the UK right
national sovereignty is not the only
value it is a serious political value in
my view because it it is the thing which
enables you to say we not just I and him
and he and so on but we we're doing this
together you've got to have some way of
identifying the first person plural if
you were to make coherent action in the
face of threat you can't do that by
identifying yourself as a global citizen
that's just a way of copping out of
saying it's not my problem it's the
world's problem and people don't give
their lives for their global citizenship
they do for their national sovereignty
and that's a very important fact what
Kant meant in perpetual peace was not
that people should relinquish national
sovereignty entirely he his view was
that that there should be a League of
Nations but there would be of genuine
nation-states which he defined as
Republic's they were in other words
their states which were fully
represented the people that they that
were members of them and I'm totally in
favor of that as long as it's does not
involve the relinquish inner sovereignty
so I think I'll be happy to to go along
with what Kant is really meaning and but
I would be aware of in doing so of
getting rid of the only thing that
enables us to fight anything in the
first place I'm all in favor of idealism
as long as you can confine it in a place
in a talking shop among
intellectuals you know the Nexxus
Institute is a perfect place for
idealism but when it escapes from that
enclosed container into the outside
world you know it can be incredibly
dangerous because most people are not
capable of of thinking in an idealistic
way most people are self-interested and
rightly so probably and without the
capacity to entertain these great ideas
so I think of ideals as a kind of
agreeable poison like wine and to be
consumed among consenting adults in
private
you've mentioned actually and I'm almost
convinced but I'm sure that even you
have some reasons to stay yes so what
are those and please know economic
reasons mmm
well of course my love of Europe and the
ease of travelling around Europe is a
wonderful thing this is something that's
happened in my lifetime and is a reason
for me
of course personally and and friendships
that have been built up across Europe my
father's my parents generation they
weren't those sort of friendships I have
a network of friends in France Italy
Poland and Czech Republic Slovakia here
in the Netherlands Belgium up to a point
you know this is this is something that
my parents could never have envisaged
and I do find that a great inspiration
but on the other hand I'm an
intellectual who reads books and lacks
languages and I'm not sure that the same
is true of the mass of ordinary English
people
advantages of the UK of staying in the
European Union gosh I have racked my
head about this and so far I haven't
found one but you know there are things
that can look like advantages but as you
say if I'm not allowed to say with
things that economists say then I can't
really give an answer from what you said
I understand that the only reason to
stay it's purely economical well what I
conclude from this is that all these
ideals and principles can just simply be
bought
which is quite a sad conclusion to reach
after one hour it might that wrong yes
you are wrong because I am talking about
ideals and principles in talking about I
was talking about national sovereignty
the rule of law and the nature of law as
we and Britain know and love it the
nature of the of the country the the
language and the culture that that is
installed there these are not economic
factors these are what go to define the
my sense of the moral idea of my country
and I don't want to lose that moral idea
it is to that idea that I appealed in
times of need and you know when I when
I'm wondering whether I shouldn't
emigrate anyway you know those that
those are the things that matter and I
think all of us have that I know this
because I'm although I'm an English
patriot I'm also a French nationalist
and Czech nationalist you know these are
things which which are deep in my soul
because of my own experience I love
those countries too and I have the same
sense that there are they represent
something more than just economic
arrangements between people so I don't
think I'm it's fair to accuse me of
reducing everything to you know things
that can be bought and so
on the country I think it's this whole
debate is a precise about the things
which can't be bought and sold you know
better than anybody else
Europe's history and we know the history
of what happened in Italy and we know
about those dark forces which car
everywhere now in Europe the only look
I'm on your side with all the criticism
we can have at European Union we will
publish Thomas already mentioned a book
in which we will claim look it's not a
European Union it's an economic unit is
nothing to do with the idea of you etc
etc etc but is all of that argument
enough to give up you know the one
fragile Institute we are having now
which which keeps the whole bloody thing
a little bit together we have seen the
balkan wars and no we don't need that
much to pull a lot of trouble off and
again breaks it easily could be you know
that kind of force due for I just don't
agree with that prediction I think that
we've now lived together in a state of
peace for long enough to recognize that
that all these conflicts are amenable to
a negotiated solution we are its and
when it comes to the big questions
confronting us now the European Union's
way of dealing with them I'm actually
pushing us in the direction that you you
were frightened off the the the rest are
at the resuscitation of tribalism but as
I say I don't have a clear monopoly over
the future and I think nobody in this
room has that really we've got to think
about principles and what it is that
gives people a sense of identity in the
first place talking about saving Europe
what should we your people from Europe
do to save Europe well you should
first of all gosh what should you you
should marry and have children not
necessarily in that order I recognize
but they that things have change but and
you should hold on to the great culture
of Europe and if possible to the
religion of Europe and to the great
tradition of Roman law and say that
these are things that we have when we
believe them we want to pass them on
that's what I would say